[Musique]
la parole est un monsieur christian
jacob
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
à quelques jours du processus de
déconfinement le doute est plus fort que
jamais c'est doute s'est installé dès
les premiers jours de la crise sanitaire
il s'installe et parce que très vite les
français ont compris que nous n'étions
pas prêts ils s'installaient aussi parce
que vous avez changé d'avis sur beaucoup
de choses et souvent sur les masques sur
les tests sur l'ouverture des écoles sur
les mesures de quarantaine pour les
ressortissants de l'union européenne sur
la date du déconfinement tout le monde
comprend le doute et le doute est
légitime lorsqu'il précède la décision
mais les approximations les ordres et
les contreurs de vos ministres
les controverses entre eux et parfois
même à votre égard sont de plus en plus
insupportable à votre décharge le
plaisir de la république ne vous êtes
pas au contraire par ses prises de
positions pour le moins évolutive
il vous a faibli à chaque à chacune de
ses interventions
pourtant monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez eu tout au long de cette
période une opposition parlementaire qui
a toujours été force de proposition qui
a toujours agi en responsabilité et des
élus locaux qui en permanence ont
cherché à combler les failles et les
faiblesses de l'état
mais où en est la france aujourd'hui
nous pleurons à ce jour trois fois plus
de morts que l'allemagne pour un nombre
de malades similaires notre produit
intérieur brut chute beaucoup plus vite
et beaucoup plus fort que chez la
plupart de nos voisins
et lorsque l'on demande aux peuples
d'europe s'ils sont satisfaits de
l'action de leurs dirigeants
le jugement est cruel merkel comptait
courte johnson tous font mieux
ma question est donc simple monsieur le
premier ministre pourquoi ces mauvais
résultats
et quels enseignements en tirez-vous
[Musique]
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre je président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député je ne vais pas et
vous évoquez beaucoup de sujets dans
votre question je peux pas les traiter
tous ici mais je voudrais dire que votre
question ad'abord le l'immense mérite de
nous imposer un exercice qui est délicat
en ce moment mais nécessaire qu'il faut
prendre avec humilité prudence celui de
la comparaison internationale
il s'agit pas de comparer ce qui n'est
que très peu comparable mais c'est utile
en effet de regarder comment confrontés
à une menace identique avec parfois des
taux de prévalence différents maires
fine menace identique les différents
pays d'europe ont réagi comment leur
système de soins s'est adapté comment
les décisions étaient prises
vous dites pour le noter et pour en
critiquer le gouvernement français ce
qui est parfaitement votre droit que
l'allemagne a observé un nombre de cas
inférieur un nombre de décès est très
largement inférieur et qu' elle devrait
donc être un exemple est allé à bien des
égards un exemple je peux parfaitement
l'entendre et partager cet avis avec
vous ne dit pas en revanche que la
comparaison avec les autres pays
comparables à la france n'est pas sur
tous les points
forcément au désavantage il médias et je
le dis avec une prudence infinie
s'agissant de la façon dont l'épidémie a
été géré vous dites que les populations
estime par exemple que le premier
ministre britannique a beaucoup mieux
géré que la situation qu'en france
peut-être sans doute c'est un point de
vue
l'opinion publique mais je le dis aussi
peut-être
et je crois qu'à la fin car un moment
nous pourrons regarder dans le détail
avec la sagesse de du regard
rétrospectif et avec l'ensemble des
données
comment notre système de soins s'est
adapté à la crise et comment celui des
pays comparables soumis aux mêmes
seraient soumis aux mêmes pressions a
réagi
je vous dire monsieur le président jacob
j'attends ce jour avec sérénité
non pas du tout avec bravoure ou avec un
quelconque enthousiasme mais j'attends
ce jour avec sérénité
j'observe que le système italien qui a
souvent été décrié à tort car vous savez
comme moi que la lombardie qui a été la
plus marquée par cette épidémie est une
région riche une région remarquablement
équipée y compris en matière de services
publics et il y compris en matière de
services publics sanitaires et bien ce
qu'on observe c'est que le système
italien
confronté à cette terrible épidémie
s'est retrouvé dans une situation où il
a vu effectuer le fameux est terrible et
tri des malades
s'agissant de l'entrée en réanimation ce
qui n'a pas été le cas en france parce
que notre système a tenu
probablement parce qu'il a eu un petit
peu plus de temps pour s'adapter
d'ailleurs que celui de nos amis
italiens comme fois je ne cherche pas à
dénigrer nos amis tout le monde est dans
une situation difficile en italie en
espagne au royaume-uni qui sont disons
le dpi par la taille
l'histoire par l'organisation
relativement relativement comparables et
donc je le dis avec tranquillité avec
humilité je sais très bien que on peut
toujours aller chercher l'exemple qui
fonctionne mieux je pense qu'il faut
aller regarder et qu'on verra à la fin
on verra à la fin comment les allemands
ont passé cette étape on verra quand
l'ensemble des données sera disponible
comment ils ont passé cette étape et je
vais vous dire s'ils n'ont pas c'est
mieux que nous eh bien d'abord je m'en
réjouirai pour eux car ce sont nos amis
et ensuite comme vous comme nous tous
ici
j'essaierai d'en tirer les leçons ce que
nous pouvons apprendre de leurs systèmes
pas simplement dans la gestion de crise
dans bien d'autres aspects comment est
ce que nous pouvons améliorer notre
système ce temps viendra vous avez
raison monsieur le député jacob sur
président jacob il viendra aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans la gestion encore
de la crise sanitaire avec des étapes
très compliqué qui sont devant nous il
ya beaucoup de gens qui savent
parfaitement que préparer le
déconfinement c'est encore plus
difficile que de décider le confinement
beaucoup plus difficile logistiquement
juridiquement politiquement humainement
techniquement c'est très difficile c'est
le travail que nous sommes en train de
faire et quand je dis nous ce n'est pas
à nous de majesté il ne s'agit pas ça
c'est les préfets et les élus locaux
c'est les chefs d'entreprise c'est
l'ensemble des acteurs du système de
soins qui essaie d'organiser les choses
pour pouvoir se conformer ou pour
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre de la façon la
plus intelligente possible les éléments
doctrine sanitaires ou d'organisation
collective qui ne sont pas faciles à
mettre en oeuvre j'en ai parfaitement
conscience parce qu'il n'est pas facile
de contrôler une épidémie
or nous devons la contrôler la contrôler
sans traitement efficace sans vaccin
sans immunité collective et donc c'est
un exercice difficile et moi dans cet
exercice difficile
j'essaie dans toute la mesure du
possible et ça n'est pas simple et vous
savez que ce n'est pas simple et
d'ailleurs vous l'avais dit à juste
titre d'apporter les éléments dont
disposent dont doivent disposer les gens
quand ils prennent les décisions pour
les mettre en inde j'essaie de faire en
sorte que la chaîne que les chaînes
départementale qui permettront de
remonter les chaînes contamination
puisse être cassée de façon à ce qu'on
évite la propagation d'épidémies
l'essai de faire en sorte que
l'approvisionnement en test soit
suffisant il sera techniquement
suffisant pour pouvoir là aussi éviter
la propagation de l'épidémie
c'est ce que fait le gouvernement
français monsieur le président jacob
britannique le gouvernement espagnol du
gouvernement italien ils le font tous
dans les conditions politiques
différentes sont parfois très critiqué
en interne ils sont très critiqués vous
avez cité les bons chiffres
je regarde ce qui se passe dans les pays
amis royaume uni en italie en espagne en
belgique
très critiqué par tous parce que tout le
monde a peur et parce que tout le monde
sait bien que nous vivons quelque chose
de retour dablement complexe il n'est
pas impossible ils ont terminé
par là monsieur le président jacob que
dans d'autres pays que le nôtre
je vais dire autrement je rencontre
beaucoup j'ai beaucoup de témoignages de
nos concitoyens qui sont très en colère
et qui en veulent beaucoup au
gouvernement j'ai aussi beaucoup de
témoignages de gens qui disent c'est
horriblement difficile ce que vous êtes
en train de faire et ce qui est en train
de faire monsieur le maire ou madame le
maire
c'est horriblement difficile de prendre
les décisions en ce moment et on le sait
tous donc allez-y courage tenez bon il
ya des pays où on ne dit peut-être plus
publiquement que chez nous c'est vrai
c'est comme ça nous vivons en france
nous aurons des leçons à retenir de
l'expérience que nous vivons des
difficultés que nous vivons
elle commanderont beaucoup de lucidité
et beaucoup de travail en commun et je
suis évidemment prêt
[Musique]